vite j'ai une main de vidic et je ne
sais quoi
il
on a compris
ces massages
[Musique]
wahou
allez devoir
[Musique]
jouer j'ai la bière du sodium comme la
fête est finie dieye branche médite sur
six romans drôme manitou a été fait
rouler comme un débutant
dans ce groupe on est une équipe vous
n'avez aucune loyauté pitié on est des
vrais méchants connais pas ce qu'on la
défend laisser la place à la jeune
génération
ap
qu'ils allaient se régale à rentrer je
pensais que c'était un homme de petite
taille c'est quoi ton problème tu crois
sérieusement qu'un petit gamin tout
gringalet peut faire un bon méchant
oui j'ai peut être hyper méchant il faut
pas me chercher moi faire le mal c'est
pour les adultes qui vole depuis sans
pierre maléfique pour semer le chaos 1
et pas pour les petits morveux potelé il
ferait mieux de l'alcool
s'instruire jouer à la récré et su
sauter leur pousse le doute me fait dire
que je ne peux pas briser ses planches
mais le doute n'existe que dans mon
esprit vous savez ce que je lui réponds
à mon esprit
[Musique]
avant trois tours
kevin cabine qui avait
[Musique]
attaqué
la pierre et mails en veilleuse
ah oui c'est vrai la pierre alors
comment dire c'est drôle vous allez
[Musique]
l'aimer petit c'est pas moi qui l'ait
joue les croix de bois croix de fer si
je mens je vais en enfer et je suis pas
su plus c'est ça qu'on m'apporte son
téléphone